han existido varios factores desde luego
un factor muy incidente fueron los
acontecimientos de octubre del año 2019
el conocido estallido de despertar
social que algunos designaron y que
desembocó con el proceso constituyente
momento en el cual a partir de los
descontentos de algunos grupos de la
sociedad válidos por los demás y la
incorporación de nuevos sectores
distintos a quienes pertenecían a
partidos políticos tanto de el staff de
candidatos y cantidades que presentaron
sus candidaturas a la convención
constitucional que actualmente está
funcionando se empezaron a dar dos
elementos fundamentales primero una
fatiga dentro del sistema de partidos en
chile- y segundo la existencia de varios
grupos que representan demandas que son
en algunos cierto punto antagónicas y en
cierto punto también incompatibles que
tienen que ver desde el orden y la
seguridad hasta la protección de
derechos sociales o la protección de la
libertad en el pleno sentido de la
expresión por lo que plantea porque lo
que plantean efectivamente algunos
sectores políticos díaz en chile que se
denomina liberal en definitiva es una
libertad más bien en términos económicos
pero un conservadurismo en términos
valóricos que era inversa lo que
plantean grupos más de izquierdas entre
izquierda incluso izquierda e izquierda
derecha mente es una mayor libertad
dentro de los términos valóricos éticos
o morales y un conservadurismo o un
control más bien del estado en materia
económica que asegure la provisión de
bienes básicos que nosotros conocemos
habitualmente como derechos sociales